>> ♪ ♪
>> Sean: A LOT OF NEWS TODAY.
COUNSEL TO THE PRESIDENT
KELLYANNE CONWAY WITH US.
I WANT TO GET TO THE EAGLES.
THE ATTACKS ON THE FIRST LADY.
YOU AND IVANKA HAVE GONE THROUGH
IT.
WHERE IS ALL OF THIS LIBERAL
RESPECT FOR WOMEN?
THE FIRST LADY PUTS OUT
STATEMENTS I AM RECOVERING.
I JUST HAD SURGERY AND I WAS
SEEN IN PUBLIC YESTERDAY.
>> WE NEED TO REVISIT THE EQUAL
RIGHTS AMENDMENT AND GET THAT
RATIFIED FROM ITS FAILED
ATTEMPTS 40 YEARS AGO.
JUST STARTING TO RESPECT EACH
OTHER REGARDLESS OF POLITICS AND
POSITION.
I WANT TO SAY A COUPLE OF THINGS
AND TAKE IT AWAY FROM ME AND
OTHERS AND BACK TO THE FIRST
LADY.
I WORK CLOSELY WITH HER AND
RESPECT HER ENORMOUSLY.
THIS COUNTRY IS BLESSED BECAUSE
SHE IS OUR FIRST LADY.
I SPEAK ONE LANGUAGE, ABOUT FIVE
LESS THAN SHE SPEAKS.
SHE ACCOMPANIES HER HUSBAND ALL
OVER THE NATION.
I WOULD TELL THE CRITICS TO LOOK
AT HER PLATFORM FOR THE
SOLUTIONS IN THIS NATION.
SHE TALKS ABOUT KINDNESS AND
RESPECT AND THE SOCIAL AND
EMOTIONAL WILL BEING OF
CHILDREN.
SHE IS TRYING TO HELP CHILDREN
WHO FEEL THEY NEED ASSISTANCE.
THAT THEY FEEL LIKE THEY ARE
BEING BULLIED AT SCHOOL PERHAPS
OR ADDICTED TO DRUGS.
I TRAVEL WITH THE FIRST LADY AND
WATCHED HER HOLD THOSE BABIES
WHO WERE BORN ADDICTED AND
STRUGGLING BECAUSE THEY WERE 1
OF 100 BABIES BORN EVERY DAY.
>> Sean: THE WAY THEY HAVE
TREATED HER IS SO OVER THE TOP
AWFUL.
WORDS CAN'T EVEN DESCRIBE IT.
>> I DON'T LIKE DIGNIFYING IT BY
DISCUSSING IT.
SHE IS SO MUCH STRONGER THAN
THAT.
>> Sean: SHE IS.
>> SHE IS THERE WITH GOLD STAR
FAMILIES.
>> Sean: SHE IS A GREAT PERSON.
>> LOOK AT THE COMPANY THE FIRST
LADY KEEPS.
SHE IS HONORING GOLD STAR
FAMILIES AND PEOPLE ARE PEDDLING
CONSPIRACY THEORIES THAT SHOULD
NOT BE DIG MY
NOT BE DIG IF
NOT BE DIG IFY
NOT BE DIG IIE
NOT BE DIG IIED
NOT BE DIG IIED O
NOT BE DIG IIED ON
NOT BE DIG IIED ON T
NOT BE DIG IIED ON THE
NOT BE DIG IIED ON THE M
NOT BE DIG IIED ON THE MAJ
NOT BE DIG IIED ON THE MAJOR
PLATFORM.
>> Sean: IN THE NFL YOU CAN'T
TAUNT OTHER PLAYERS AND DO
CERTAIN DANCES AND GESTURES.
THEY HAVE RESTRICTIONS ON
FREEDOM OF SPEECH.
YET, ROGER GOODELL IN HIS
INFINITE WISDOM, ALLOWED
EVERYTHING THAT HAPPENED LAST
YEAR.
PEOPLE WHO FOUGHT AND DIED UNDER
THAT FLAG.
I AM NOT AGAINST PROTESTING BUT
THE NFL DOES STIFLE FREEDOM OF
SPEECH IN SOME WAYS.
I AM DONE WITH THE NFL.
NOW THEY WILL LET PLAYERS HIDE
IN THE LOCKER ROOM WHICH IS
WORSE THAN BEFORE WHEN OUR
NATIONAL ANTHEM IS PLAY.
TELL US WHAT HAPPENED WITH THE
EAGLES.
>> WELL, THERE IS A LOT TO
UNPACK THERE.
THE PRESIDENT COULD NOT BE MORE
CLEAR ON HIS POSITION ON THE
NATIONAL ANTHEM.
HE MADE A SIMPLE REQUEST THAT
PEOPLE SHOULD STAND FOR THE
FLAG.
BEFORE PEOPLE SAYS EVERYBODY
STOOD FOR THE PLAG.
THIS WAS A DECISION THE
PRESIDENT MADE ON HOW THAT WAS
HANDLED.
NOT BASED ON WHAT HAPPENED LAST
SEASON.
IT IS THE NFL, NOT THE WHITE
HOUSE AND NOT THE PRESIDENT WHO
CAME OUT WITH A BRAND NEW POLICY
THAT GOVERNS WHAT ITS PLAYERS
WILL DO.
THAT'S BETWEEN THE NFL AND ITS
PLAYERS.
THEY CAME OUT WITH THE POLICY
LAST MONTH THAT PERHAPS SOME OF
THE PLAYERS ON DIFFERENT TEAMS
DON'T LIKE.
SEAN, I THINK THE PRESIDENT WAS
FOCUSSED ON THE RIGHT NUMBER.
THAT WAS THE 1,000 EAGLES FANS
THAT RESPONDED TO THE WHITE
HOUSE.
MANY OF WHOM WERE ALREADY IN
TOWN EXPECTING TO COME TO THE
WHITE HOUSE.
HE DECIDED TO RESPECT THEIR
EFFORT IN COMING AND THEIR
EXCITEMENT AND STILL WELCOME
THEM TO THE WHITE HOUSE AND
CONVERT IT INTO A CELEBRATE
AMERICA EVENT.
IT WAS A FABULOUS EVENT TODAY
WITH THE MARINE CORP BAND AND
SONGS.
THERE WERE A LOT OF EAGLES
PLAYERS WHO VOTED FOR DONALD
TRUMP AND SUPPORT MANY OF HIS